[Music]
gavin is with us in minnesota hi gavin
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you very much guys how are you
today better than we deserve brother how
can we help
so my wife and i currently
live in a 600 square foot apartment
we are seventeen thousand dollars in
debt uh with a truck that um my i had to
get for my job and we have an
opportunity to rent to own five acres
with a 900 square foot cabin on it that
needs about five grand of improvements
to make it livable and i'm not entirely
sure what course of action to take
while i'm trying to do the baby steps in
this situation
you don't have the money
correct well we have uh five thousand
dollars saved up um in addition to our
emergency fund of a thousand dollars
without um and that's not including
retirement
but that saving is in mutual funds and
bleed we're not entirely sure if we
should just be patient wait for another
opportunity in the next few years and
allow that savings to
keep growing or because we're on baby
step two cancel all of that um extra
investing into mutual funds and then um
take out that money to make the
improvements and then
do 500 a month on a rent to own rather
than renting a property that we're only
temporarily
living in
um gavin how old are you guys
i am 20 and my wife is 21.
[Music]
okay
um
well let's walk through a couple of
things here um one is i want to go back
and revisit the statement your work
requires you to go into debt to buy them
a truck
i'm so confident that is correct
i'm so confused
what's your home
my wife works part-time and she brings
in about six hundred dollars a month and
then i bring in about twenty four
hundred dollars a month why does she
work part-time
well she applied for a full-time
position but she's only getting
part-time hours right now
and she is pregnant so she doesn't want
to
start a full-time position right before
going on maternity leave that matters
okay that that's good information all
right now
um and you make
30 000 a year and you have a seventeen
thousand dollar truck
correct yeah
okay
well it was twenty four thousand but
then we've been attacking it so now it's
down to seventeen but yeah but it's
insanity
so why do they require you to buy a
truck why don't they furnish you a truck
um that would be that is a great
question i have to like i put on 5000
miles a month
supervising 13 different hog barns and
they require me to have a
decent vehicle they do pay me mileage so
they they do pay
for the insurance with that pension they
pay for the insurance and the
minimum payment however all that debt is
still in my name not theirs
okay you don't get paid enough
for them to do this to you
and you to accept it
your deal
sucks
60 000 miles a year on a pickup truck
you know what you're doing to the value
of that pickup truck you're destroying
down down down yeah you're destroying
the value of that pickup truck
and so you're you're actually probably
paying them to work there when all the
smoke clears on this
just because the value of the truck
decreases so rapidly i mean when you
when you lose when you make thirty
thousand dollars a year and you lose ten
thousand dollars for the opportunity
that doesn't work dude yeah i have a
quick question on the they require you
to have a decent vehicle what does that
mean that feels means they want him to
be able to get to 13 different hog barns
yeah without breaking right they want me
to put on that many miles a year without
it breaking down on me and be
they uh because of biosecurity reasons
just because there's so many um hogs so
i don't spread diseases at the bee
um and i have to transport some other
individuals so it has to be a crew cab
it has to be leather seats so it can be
disinfected um on a regular basis
i was going to say because i was going
to come at the i can get you a much more
affordable truck that'll get you to all
those hog farms but that's a whole
nother deal yeah this is right they're
ripping them off
your employer are completely asinine
this is ridiculous
that they require all of this for you
and you work your butt off for the no
more money than you're making
i mean they really got
some nerve
um so are you in a a
very ru extremely rural area
uh yes yeah okay
all right i mean
i would say eighty percent of the miles
are on um are on the interstate doesn't
matter
but
is this a long term play for you do you
want to be in this particular industry
and this is a really good run on the
ladder to get you where you want to go
this is not my dream job and i do not
want to have this job until i retire if
that answers your question
what is your dream job
my dream job is to be able to uh
to really farm full-time but that's not
attainable anywhere in the near future
right so my question is is this job
right now besides the fact you're
getting ripped off is it strategic for
you you feel like this is the rung on
the ladder i need to be on to keep
climbing towards farming or no
um to have the amount of income that i
do
i doubled my income when i moved to this
job
so and right now i don't seem to have
any other opportunities super close to
home in order to maintain that income
within ten thousand dollars both ways
a year
um without
without driving an hour and a half to
two hours to work
wow
how open to
moving outside of this area are you and
your
uh wife
not very just let me stop let me just
stop you for a second with what they're
costing you by requiring this truck you
guys are living below the poverty level
that's why we're so concerned yeah
you're you're not making any money
you you're livi it's a moro it's a
mathematical mirage
because you're destroying 25 000 while
you're making thirty thousand
and um the this requirement uh that
they've got on a 21 year old young man
and or at least you've accepted it as a
requirement is not it's just
unreasonable
um and so they either need to furnish
you a truck or you need to look for a
job
somewhere else and that may mean a move
it may mean uprooting your family but
no you don't need to buy this cabin
you're broke and in debt and your career
sucks
so you've got to get some of those
things fixed first before you start
talking about doing a rent to own on a
fixer-upper cabin
so um
um i i think you got to solve your job
situation in this truck situation
because this truck needs to go bye-bye
and if that means the job goes bye-bye
you need to have something lined up hold
on i'm going to have ken send you a copy
of have the team send you a copy of
ken's book paycheck to purpose
because
you know you called about the cabin the
cabin's not your issue no you don't buy
the cabin